هل يمكنني الحصول على هاتفي ، من فضلك ،
إنه مثل ملك صغير على عرشه ،
عرشًا من الأثاث المعبأ ، تمكن بطريقة
ما من طلبه من وول مارت بإجمالي
786 دولارات ، ولا عجب أن والده أضاف
الشعار الذي أحب التسوق ،
كانت زوجتي تفكر في أنني فعلت ذلك ولكن
بعد ذلك أنا  كنت أفكر في
أنه يجب أن اتضح أنه فعل ذلك ، فقد
وضعت والدته عشرات الكراسي أو نحو ذلك في
عربة التسوق الخاصة بها في وول مارت وهي تنوي
اختيار زوجين في وقت لاحق ، لكن أيان كومار البالغ من العمر 22 شهرًا
أمر بكل شيء باستخدام
هاتف
والدته لم يدركه والديه حتى
يأتي الناس مع الصناديق الكبيرة
وكانوا يسقطون للتو ، لذا
أتى صندوق واحد لعبتين مربعتين الآن هناك
كومة عملاقة من الصناديق في
تقاطع مونماوث الجديد في المنزل غير مفتوح
لأنهم يأملون في إرجاع معظمها
يبدو أن وول مارت مستعد نعم العميل
شخص خدمة كانت تضحك كثيرًا
يا إلهي لكنهم لن يعيدوا
كل شيء ، لذلك نفكر في الاحتفاظ
ببعض العناصر كذكرى تذكارًا صغيرًا
من فورة التسوق الأولى ، نعم
لقد أعاد كومار  نقلت بطاقة الخصم الخاصة بهم
من الحساب حتى لا تتسبب الأيونات في
المزيد من الضرر بالنسبة لـ 1786 دولارًا ، حسنًا ،
لقد حصلت على الكثير من الكراسي لذلك ،
أعلم هل تريد ذلك
حتى أنهم يخبرون الجيران
أن هذا هو المنزل
الطفل الصغير المشهور عالمياً في نيو جيرسي
ونجم الروك الصغير
عندما يسمع ابنهما في يوم من الأيام اهتمام
المتسوقين ، فهذا يعني أنك ربما تكون
أصغر جني متسوق في وول
مارت أكثر من سي إن إن
نيويورك